there are people who are afraid of men
dressing up like women and acting crazy
and um you know that's look
not here to judge anybody if like they
said if a parent doesn't want their
children around it then they don't need
to be there they can make the decision
it's very simple um at
the same at the same time if a parent
wants to go to with their child to a
drag reading hour they should be able to
do that and they should be able to have
fun they shouldn't have to be protested
and they shouldn't have to be
interrupted by proud boys the drag queen
exists in
from a sexual nature that's what it's
the drag queen is for they only take
basically two qualities of a woman
and and they don't they don't focus on
intelligence they don't focus on work
ethic they don't focus on anything
nurturing they don't focus on
just the sexual and the materialistic
side
and so why would we want to teach kids
that's what a woman is
why would we want to do that and besides
that
what what would be the benefit to having
a female stripper sit down and read to
the kids
[Music]
welcome to my podcast i'm michaela
peterson this is the michaela peterson
podcast and this is an opposing views
episode on drag story time and drag
shows
posing views is a series where i speak
with individuals on opposite sides of a
contentious issue and this issue is
definitely contentious it was very
interesting
on one side i had john casey a widely
published writer for the advocate a
lgbtq the largest lgbtq magazine in the
u.s
on the other side of this debate i had
brian slaton a former youth minister and
current state representative of texas in
the last few months you guys have
probably seen there have been a number
of viral videos showing parents bringing
children to drag shows
a lot of people and parents especially
have been upset by that a lot of people
have supported it
drag shows in bars
drag story time in libraries
drag story time at the toronto zoo
in this episode we discussed those
videos the history of drag in the us
drag isn't something new the difference
between drag shows and other drag events
like drag queen's story time
grooming why drag is an issue now
age requirements for attending drag
shows and a lot more a special thanks to
john casey for coming on this episode
he's on the left and given my more
right-leaning audience i do appreciate
getting left-wing people on here to hear
their opinions about political issues
because we do need to continue hearing
both sides so please remember to be kind
to the participants so i can get more
people to agree to come on and discuss
these issues and i can keep doing
opposing views thank you so much for
listening i hope you enjoyed this
episode before we get into it though
you're probably aware that inflation
recently reached its highest rate since
1985. and i don't think anyone knows for
sure how bad it is going to get
hopefully things stabilize again sooner
rather than later you can hope for that
anyway i don't know if things are going
to get worse there's a apparently a food
shortage things might get really bad you
can invest your money with goldco though
they sponsored this episode they're a
leader in gold and silver retirement
accounts gold ira
it's wise to protect your life savings
especially right now
while you can by investing in precious
metals like gold and silver my family
has money in precious metals so i'm not
just saying that through gold co you get
a guaranteed way to protect the worth of
your financial assets and retirement
savings even though inflation reduces
the worth of your money in the bank the
value of gold and silver
has historically been a lot more stable
especially during inflation
over the last decade gold go has made it
possible for thousands of americans to
protect over a billion dollars in
retirement savings
with more than one thousand star
customer ratings gold co is an easy
place to start safeguarding your
retirement and right now they're
offering a promotion that gives
qualifying new customers up to ten
thousand dollars in free silver which is
a pretty sweet deal you can diversify
your investments today by visiting
mplikesgold.com and they'll give you up
to ten thousand dollars in free silver
when you open a qualifying account
that's
mplakesgold.com
tell them that i sent you and enjoy this
episode
john casey welcome to my podcast well
thank you for having me nice to be here
great yeah thank you very much for
coming on before we get started can you
give me a brief background about who you
are and what it is you do
sure well i'm i
i've been in
public relations most of my life still
am
to a certain extent but i worked on
capitol hill at the beginning of my
career for about seven years
moved to new york and worked for a
couple of international pr agencies and
then ran media relations for ceos and
kmart toys r us and macy's and then i
worked for three years
with the united nations on climate
change to the run-up to the paris
accords simultaneously i worked for um
mike bloomberg when he was u.n climate
envoy and then i'd been in um
digital for the last few years doing uh
a pr for some digital companies so and
then on the side i uh i do two columns
per week for the advocate where i touch
on societal political entertainment and
topical news issues that affect the
lgbtq community so i have an opportunity
to speak with you know all of the
leaders and
all of the great voices in the lgbtq
community and
it's been an awesome
way to get to know people and um
and to be able to cover uh
what's
who who's affected you know serious
issues political issues um spoke you
know to most of the out members of
congress uh i spoke to ellen when she
left her show she only spoke to me and
one other reporter um i i spoke to
shirley maclaine yesterday so i have a
great column coming up about her so i it
just um
you know i get to take the column in
different ways and then i've written
about uh drag queens so um i i feel like
that i've uh
been able to touch on most of the issues
that affect the community
okay perfect well i invited you on um to
get your perspective on drag queen drag
queens shows and the most recent kind of
media frenzy that's involved having kids
attend drag queen shows so that was
maybe two months ago that that kind of
blew up online
yeah well they're not attending drag
queen shows they're going to drag drag
queen reading hours so there's a big
difference there
i don't know if you've ever been to a
drag queen show but um
it's a little rivalled and
uh the the it's entertainment and um
uh when i take for when friends come
into new york city to see me straight
friends we go to what's called drag
brunch uh it's a real popular thing in
new york and they're
so much fun and even in miami uh the
palace uh bar which is um
on ocean drive they have drag
happy hour which is enormously popular
you can't go anywhere near that place
the sidewalks are full the traffic is
stopped so drag shows are one thing then
you have drag reading hours which
libraries do mostly public libraries i
do for kids and it's just a way for kids
to be engaged in a book to someone who
is an entertainer
okay um do you think that
the idea of exposing kids to drag queens
is too sexual for people at a certain
age
well it's not sexual it's um
first of all i think i think the biggest
reason people have probably
misperception misconceptions about um
drag queens is because they haven't met
them or they haven't seen them um
drag queens are entertainers um and when
they are in a setting of a library
reading a book they're there to have fun
with kids just like anybody else would
except there they are dressed in you
know very flamboyant costumes um so
it's
they're not imparting any
uh
sexual identity or
or talking about themselves or talking
about what they do they're there just to
read a story and help the kids along
with the story and
make sure the kids have fun um it's not
threatening in the least
certainly you would never take a child
to um a drag brunch for example that
that's all
out of a question or drag show but with
the drag happy hour or i'm sorry with it
with the drag reading hour it's it
it's innocent it's just fun
so i i think the
um i think it i think it was about two
months ago the event that had people all
up in arms i believe that was an actual
drag show that it was in called drag
your kids to pride
did you see the clips of that show going
on online yeah but there again i think
that um is up to the parents
that is solely a parent's responsibility
to decide whether they want to take
their child to that or not um it's not
up to me to tell a parent when it's age
appropriate for them uh
to see something like that so that is
totally a parental judgment um and
and if they want to take their kids and
and and take them to a pride event or
pry drag share thing again that is that
is a parent's call and parents have
every right to be able to make the
decision on that
um how do you feel about the recent
legislature that's trying to be advanced
that
puts kind of drag shows into the same
category as strip shows and says no
parents can't take their kids there they
can go once they're 18 or 21.
well it's all political i i think
through this particularly through this
midterm uh election the lgbtq community
has really been
um
singled out um and used for our
political purposes so you you have that
one you have don't say gay um in florida
and you know primarily that
that's
um
but there's a lot wrong with that but
the
biggest issue is that parents don't want
their kids subjected to talking about
sexual identity in kindergarten and
grade school well that's not happening
so this
that was one thing with singled out and
all these states are trying to replicate
what ron desantis which they can't
really do and then as a matter of fact
there are other states that do have the
don't say gay laws on the book then you
have what's going on with trans youth
and and politicians using trans youth as
a um as a political wedge issue um
you're gonna have uh um
not just trans youth but transgender
people too
um there's been a lot of
what you just referenced these bills
which are not
addressing any problem um there is not a
problem of parents swarming into drag
shows with their children in tow that
doesn't happen and you know uh and most
bars aren't going to let kids in if it's
a pride event again it's it's out in the
public it's up to the it's up to the
parent same thing with with you know a
drag reading hour if the parents aren't
comfortable with it they don't have to
send their kids so these bills that are
popped up are for problems that are
non-existent and they're just being used
as political wedge issues
hmm
interesting um do you think so one of
the concerns that's on the more
conservative or republican side is that
um say say
the number of trans youth in the last
15 years has increased dramatically and
they believe that that's because there's
an ideology being pushed in public
schools and so part of the kind of
pushback against this is oh i don't want
you to teach my kids this ideology
because they're concerned they'll be
pushed into a
into an ideology so how do you feel
about that well it's not an ideology um
you're born gay um and you're born
whether you are a
a child you know a teenager who feels
that they are a boy or a girl um you
know it's inherent in you yes it's been
been on the horizon there's been many
arguments and
[Music]
discussion points of what why that has
been and i think chief among them and
having talked to trans youth is that
there's um
people
uh kids are more open today and and
there are um
role models for for these kids somebody
like elliot page who who who who is is
brave enough to be able to come forward
and and admit the fact that they they
feel that they are a male
and so um and then
you can see what's going on on the right
i mean just yesterday marjorie taylor
green dead named um uh assistant
secretary of health rachel levine i know
her i've talked to her
but this is an incredible person
incredibly she's incredibly smart i'm so
again all of these things i feel like
are trying to
are trying to get people frightened uh
get people scared the fact that
transgender people are around and um
you know that that's not the case
nobody's pushing an ideology people are
people just want to be who they are
okay let me see
um do you think that there's
um this is another argument i've heard
this another argument i've heard the
dangers say
say one side is wrong there's the side
that says this is an ideology and then
there's a side that says people are born
this way and we should be open to that
so that we're not prejudiced against
people we're not hateful right those are
badly worded those are kind of the two
sides
if the conservative side is wrong um
then people are
i would say ostracized until they're
about 18 and can
transition over
right and
if the liberal side is wrong
and kids are more susceptible to these
ideas what happens if you get kids
who transition surgically or with
medication and can't transition back
okay so
those are rare cases um very very rare
um
i think we just need to take a step back
you're talking about conservative and
the liberal side but why don't you ask a
conservative parent who has a child
who
who
wants to transition because they know
they they believe and the parents have
studied the issue they talk to doctors
they talk to psychologists it's not as
if michaela that uh a child comes to
their parent and says i'm i'm a girl and
i want to be a boy and then somebody
just flips a switch in the back of their
head and there was a process to go
through a very long um
and very strenuous process to make sure
that the child
is in the right place to do something
like that you know oftentimes not
oftentimes but it does happen that the
doctors won't agree to it because they
do feel like so there are guard rails
set up for if you want to call it the
conservative side of people making what
they consider to be this drastic switch
but there's the guard rails are set up
specifically to protect the child and
again it goes all the way back to
the parents decision and how they want
to handle this and i've spoken to
so many parents who have transgender
kids that want to transition and you
know the biggest issue for them is they
see
when the child uh for example somebody i
just spoke to um who was a boy when the
the child is dressing like a girl and
and doing girl thing how happy
that child is parents know that um you
know there's always also the thing that
that mothers always know when their son
is gay it falls back on that too parents
have a general idea if their child um
might not be comfortable uh in the in
the in the identity that they were born
with and so
all of the yes there's arguments back
and forth back and forth but i think
it's very important for and they do seek
them out is for um
the parents of these youth
uh who are dealing with it to talk about
to read their stories to reach out to
them um they're they're not liberal or
conservative they're just parents and
they want to do what's best for their
kids
um do you know
could you give a brief description of
what a drag show is for anyone who
doesn't know and when they started
oh okay well
you know
drag has been around forever um and it's
been um
and i'll just stick to the u.s it's a
lot of history in in europe but in the
u.s i'm sure
you don't know what vaudeville is most
most younger people don't but vaudeville
was
really the um
the entertainment
venue for lack of a better term back at
the turn of the century and there were
traveling shows where they did song and
dance and told
really bad jokes but
most of the uh
performers were men and they dressed
like women and they did songs and they
did dances and and people came out to
see them and so that was the early early
type of of what we consider to be drag
um a lot of them were called
transvestites which you know is not
a word that means anything in today but
back then that that's what they were
called and then you can go through i
mean uh
my own personal knowledge on this is
that um you know
somebody like milton berle you say who
was milton berle well back in the early
late 40s and early 50s he was
television's biggest star
he was also one of the most famous
comedians in the world he spent
most of his career he dressed like a
woman and of course it was for fun it
was making jokes and um but he probably
was the most famous drag queen
um in in hollywood for for a long time
and then came along um flip wilson in
the late 60s he had a television show
and he created a character named
geraldine and so geraldine was trying
again so did you know do you know about
that yeah yeah i think i've seen that
i'm familiar with vaudeville too oh yeah
i'm sure you are because you're a very
intelligent person so um thank you i'm
i'm not just saying that so um
yeah so then you you know martin
lawrence has done it uh jamie foxx has
done it look at medea um and the success
of medea
he's in drag um and then i don't know if
he saw first ladies on show time but you
know uh eleanor roosevelt went into a
gay bar um there were drag shows people
were dressing like eleanor roosevelt and
they dressed like betty davis and karma
miranda so all of this all of this has
been around and then look at look at
television some like bosom buddies that
was an emmy award-winning show and uh
tootsie which won the oscar dustin
hoffman was in drag
nutty professor
kinky boots the
terrific performance by philip seymour
hoffman and flawless where where he
played a drag queen so
it's it's and some like it hot with uh
tony curtis and jack lemmon you know
that was back in the early 60s so
the drag uh of of men like entertainers
dressing as women has been a long for
been around for a long time and so if
you want uh
back to your now question about a drag
show so
you know drag shows mostly are um
performers um who come out and lip sync
and dance the songs some of them sing
for real um they usually intersperse
their performance with with jokes
they rip on the audience it's it's fun
it's
it's hilarious um you know it's adult
entertainment it's adult entertainment
um because it's done in bars or or you
know um
restaurants where it's no holds bars
it's terrific
um so that would be a drag show and then
like i explained there's a drag brunch
where um you go into
very popular in new york so many places
now do drag
but you go in and you gotta have an hour
and a half a bottomless mimosas and drag
performers come and they dance and sing
and you feel like you're in a club and
it's really it's really a great way to
spend uh early uh afternoon from
saturday and sundays um so those are
drag shows and then i i told you about
the one in miami
at the palace which is
the
it's a it's epic i mean you can't walk
around this anywhere near the palace
when they do their drive happy hour and
the drag performers run out on the
street and they're lip-syncing songs
they're dancing with the crowd it's
really you know it's not gay people it's
predominantly straight people who stop
and watch this so
drag has been um and then one final
thing i guess other um rupaul drag race
i mean that show is is uh
you know emmy nominated it's um
it's one of the trendiest shows out
there and a lot of the performers on
there have gone on and done other things
for example um i think it was uh
american idol one of them performed an
american idol so
um so drag queens are everywhere um
drake shows are everywhere most
everywhere and um
there are lots of fun there are
entertainers first and foremost um drag
queens are entertainers
um i went to a drag show when i was in
new york um i think i was uh i was
definitely i was probably 15 i think and
it was
yeah i'm not sure how i snuck in there
but it was like it was mostly i think
most of the people in there in the place
i went to were bachelorettes
so
bachelorettes
like bachelorette parties yeah i from
what i remember i think it was mostly
bachelorette parties
yes that happens to you there's a lot of
bachelor that's a really a popular thing
for um
for batch bachelorette parties is to go
to a drag show um
it's so much fun it really is and
there's no
um
there's there's no political statement
being made about oh we should all be
able to dress in in track or and it's
fun they're entertainers they're just
there to make the crowd laugh to make
the crowd happy that that's all they
want to do
so do you think that this event that
happened a couple of months ago that
kind of went viral particularly i think
in conservative realms do you think that
was more which
with kids going to a drag show do you
think that was more of an isolated
incident
yes exactly and i'm wondering why
um we're not talking about the proud
boys uh which are going around
interrupting drag
uh reading hours and libraries and see
this is the issue i always say well you
know i saw all the commotion about that
more it's more of a one-off you are
correct but why are they talking about
um uh proud boys going into these um
drag reading hours and disrupting them
that's worse for the kids i mean they're
seeing
out and out racists
come into their
little happy
reading hour and
disrupting with hateful language and
hateful speech and the the
these drag reading hours are are being
targeted by proud boys which in turn
are are making some of the libraries
having to cancel them because they are
they fear that the
these people will interrupt them and
that's really
that's sickening um
that that you know the same people who
are going out there condemning jews and
black people are trying to
um are trying to call out in in the most
horrific ways drag queens in front of
children it's really
um it's really appalling and
i think it just shows the the
the danger
in trying
um to use
uh somebody like a drag queen as a
political wedge issue because what that
does is stir up hate and when the hate
is stirred up then
these um
these facets
groups these racist groups follow and
and that's the tragedy of the whole
thing i think it's it's gone too far
when when something like that happens
um
what do you think about um okay i'm not
super familiar with this issue but i'm
gonna so i might get some things wrong
but um apparently there was a bill i
think introduced in california that made
learning about
drag queens and drag shows mandatory in
school did you hear about this that was
introduced yeah but
again i
you know
it's hard to take something like that
serious um nobody
going back to what i keep saying
this
being a drag queen is not a political
issue and nobody wants to
force people to think about drag queens
and so um
to me this is just trying um
to match
uh
the hate on the other side by putting up
another bill that
makes the whole thing a wash i just you
know nobody the governor of california
is not going to sign a bill well it
won't be passed that makes it mandatory
to learn about drag shows i mean that's
ludicrous on the same end is why would
uh what's going on with making them uh
some bills are out there to try to make
them illegal same thing i mean these are
two
way extremes it's not about drag queens
it's about entertaining children and
giving them an uh a a new way of
learning and of having fun and engaging
and engaging in a story
okay
let me see what else i have here that we
haven't covered
um
do you think there's room
for
i guess nuance in the debate
so that
drag shows are fine you can say because
there are very conservative people in
america you can say you know what drag
has been around forever it's
entertainment drag shows are fine
however
we can
borrow it from children and put it in
the same category as more adult
entertainment and that's reasonable do
you think that's something
that both sides could agree on
well uh
drag shows or drag reading hours are not
adult entertainment so there's a huge
difference there and i've talked to drag
queens who do
uh drag reading hours they
they go and do their drag show where
they have all their fun and ripping on
the crowd and you know
being
you know being crazy and then they have
where they read to children it's not a
when the when they drag queen is reading
in front of children it's not about
entertainment and so
that's a it's a huge huge misnomer
they're not in the library being rivaled
and dancing around they're reading a
story to kids and they're making it fun
for them so
so you talk about the nuance you know at
the end of the day it's up to the parent
that the parent is not comfortable
sending a child to a drag reading out
then don't do it
um but but but don't go and try
to you know make maybe
this sounds a little
harsh and brash but keep your nose in
your own business there are parents who
think it's great go in there and they
and they sit with the kids they're
dropping the kids off and then leaving
them there alone with a drag queen you
know that's what the
what the these parents who are against
that wants you to think that somehow
this drag queen is
brainwashing these kids about being a
drag queen that's not it at all the
parents the drag queen makes it just as
fun for the parents reading the book you
know they they have um it's interactive
so um
if but if you're strongly against it and
you don't want your kids uh to be there
then then don't send them there that's
your decision nobody's gonna tell you
you have to do it just
do it that's your decision keep them at
home but let the people who would love
to have their children experience lots
of fun and entertainment with the drag
queen and then let them do it it's a
parent's decision
okay
okay um do you think i guess last
question that kind of goes in that
direction do you think that
um the idea of having drag queen story
time is
because of
what a drag queen represents is kind of
hyper sexual just by itself whether or
not they're doing the show is it not
kind of hypersexual for
kids
no it's it's not i mean kids aren't
you know i i i
when i wrote a column about this
initially i talked to uh my friend david
berta who married to neil patrick harris
and they have two kids and um you know
they were
uh
their kids are terrific kids just
terrific kids but you know david talked
about um the fact that they're fine with
letting their kids
uh be with drag queens so long as
they're not rude or raunchy and you know
the kids got a different exposure to it
because their dad neil patrick harris
starred in kinky boots so they took them
to kinky boots and you know they
explained to the kids that the drag is a
celebration of life it's about embracing
differences and that's that's what it is
and so they saw their dad in it and then
they thought it was fun you know um
they weren't telling the kids you know
uh they weren't making it sexual they
were making the fact of what honest to
god is it's just entertainment and i
think that's really important is that
it's not sexualized in any way unless
the parent
makes it sexualized now
going back to that
david and neil produced the uh a drag
film for hbo called wigs and
yeah that's about drag shows it's about
drag queen but they don't want their
kids to see that that's not for kids
it's for adults so yes they take them to
a drag reading hour they'll take their
dads they'll take them what's your dad
be um
kinky boots but they they didn't let the
kids watch wigs because wigs is not for
children
okay so do you think it's possible that
um the
more conservative media is just hyper
fixating on certain examples um and
that's blowing making things look
skewed
yes i i totally agree with you on that
that's what it is it's a political issue
um
there are you said it there are people
who are afraid of men dressing up like
women and acting crazy and um
you know that's look
not here to judge anybody if like they
said if a parent doesn't want their
children around it then they don't need
to be there they can make the decision
it's very simple um at
the same at the same time if a parent
wants to go to with their child to a
drag reading hour they should be able to
do that and they should be able to have
fun and they shouldn't have to be
protested and they shouldn't have to be
interrupted by proud boys it's something
that's
specifically done for kids
it's not
it's not some
wild
raunchy show it's a simple nice way for
kids to have a good time it just so
happens that the drag queen
okay
um let me see what else do i have to
cover that covered quite a bit
and thank you again for coming on oh
sure i'm glad i could talk about this i
feel like um i think you had some really
good questions so i appreciate that
thanks
uh let me see
there was one more thing i wanted to ask
let me see if i can remember it sure
okay yeah oh one of so one of the things
you hear in more conservative circles
quite frequently is that these
um
drag reading hours are
grooming children how do you feel about
that assertion
oh that is
it's awful let me let me be really frank
with you i was groomed by a priest okay
and abused by a priest so
i know what grooming is
and when you're trying to
put
that label on somebody that's almost
like calling them a murderer and that is
wrong in every every facet of anything
you can even bring that up that is wrong
they are not grooming the children my
god the parents are there and they're
watching these with kids they're not
grooming the kids
and for anyone to use that word
flippantly
and particularly to a drag queen who's
just reading a book
is is wrong it's very very very
dangerous and um
it's downright evil
when you have been groomed you know how
horrible that is and when somebody goes
out and throws the word grooming or
pedophile
and it is a it's wrong and a dangerous
and all of that needs to stop
and i'm worried that it isn't stopping i
see marjorie taylor green on
on twitter using those words it's um
it's and it's horribly offensive to
somebody who has been groomed
okay thank you for sharing that
okay okay one one more
sure just looking at my list i'm like
maybe one more um is there any type of
argument within the lgtp sorry lgbtq
community is there any argument about um
whether or not
drag reading time is appropriate for
kids
oh i'm sure there is i mean we're not
like one um
monolithic
way of thinking so i almost certainly
there's you know i they don't even have
to be conservative i mean it's a it's a
parent's choice whether you're a liberal
conservative
uh communist whatever you are
independent it's your choice and some
people don't feel comfortable
with their kids in that with a drag
queen reading hour that that's fine
that's your decision and yeah so within
the lgbt community i'm sure that um that
there are parents you know two moms or
two dads who say you know that's not for
my kids and that's fine just like it
would be for a straight parent that's
fine if you feel that way but don't go
labeling these people wrongly by calling
them a groomer and pedophile don't be
protesting them um you know
don't be don't try to marginalize them
but that's the wrong thing to do in the
end it hurts kids because if kids think
there's something wrong with that then
you know you're you're already uh
bringing an element of discrimination if
you don't want to take your kids into
that reading hour then just don't bring
it up
that's it
okay is there anything else you want to
cover that or quite any information you
want out there that i haven't covered
no i think you hit some really good
questions i appreciate that um and i you
know you're i'm i appreciate the fact
that you're looking at it from the other
side so
um and give you an opportunity to be
able to explain it a little bit more so
so people have more of an open mind and
and understand it more rather than just
lashing out so and may i say one more
thing if you have the opportunity to
meet a drag queen go meet them because
you're gonna find that they're just a
human being just like you and i
i love it okay well thank you very much
john for coming on if people want to
follow you online is there anywhere they
can go
yeah i'm on twitter um
and then i uh you can just push the the
advocate
lgbtq john casey and i have a link to
all my columns on there
okay great thank you very much again
well thank you it was really nice to
meet you okay have fun in florida i am
okay bye-bye now this episode is
sponsored by nordvpn if you followed the
show for a while then you probably
already know because i've complained
about it a lot how bad canadian netflix
is i mean netflix has just been bad
recently i think uh but at least it has
variety in america and if you're in the
states now like me you could use nordvpn
to find out exactly what i mean we
actually just had one of our
debit cards hacked
in an egyptian airport then i started
getting these egyptian
fees and egyptian electronic payments
going through my debit card
because my assistant used my debit card
when he was in an airport
and because he wasn't using something
like nordvpn
which he uses now so nordvpn can be very
useful especially if you're traveling
in areas where there can be hackers
around trying to grab your information
you should check them out i use nordvpn
to also watch the best shows in netflix
anywhere in the world from canada now
that i live in miami i don't use
nordvpn to watch good netflix shows
but no matter where i go i do like to
safeguard my online activity especially
when traveling nordvpn's state of the
art encryption protects you from third
parties who want to watch what you're
doing online it also protects you from
hackers malware and any malicious people
who might want to track your online
activity
nordvpn's a simple way to guarantee your
privacy and keep you safe online it's
super easy to start using it's fast it's
not slow i've used a lot of vpns and a
lot of them just slow down your internet
enough that it's not worth using a vpn
they're not like that you can grab your
exclusive nordvpn deal by going to
nordvpn.com
tmpp
nordvpn.com tmpp to get a huge discount
off your nordvpn plan plus four months
for free
and it's completely risk-free with
nord's 30-day money-back guarantee so
sign up for nordvpn and enjoy the rest
of this episode and be nice
brian slayton welcome to my podcast
thank you for having me and i'm happy to
be here
so before we get started can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
okay
say my name is brian slaton
i will start with this a wonderful wife
and two lovely kids at home she's almost
six months old and a little boy that is
four years old
um before that my background i was in
the ministry i was a youth and family
minister
and uh then winded up i got my
bachelor's and master's there and went
back to school got my accounting degree
and
got interested involved with politics
and then now i'm a state representative
i have not even completed my first term
but i've found myself fighting on
culture issues that i just believe are
the right stance to take
okay great uh well we're discussing drag
shows in this episode because
those have been all over the news and
there's
the country is split on their opinion
about
whether or not these are good for people
so i'm going to run through a couple of
questions and see how you feel about
this
first of all do you know like can you
explain what drag shows are and where
they started
yeah i mean they started uh you know
in in the gay community right men
dressing up as women uh and and it's a
characterization of woman just in the
sexual nature and materialistic uh you
know big hair makeup a big dress and
then the sexual side and you know it's
probably been part of the community a
very long time now as far as when it you
know officially started you know i i
don't know i'm guessing from things i've
read around 100 years ago but here's the
problem is drag shows have gone on
they've you know have always probably
been around in some form or fashion
but now what we're seeing is this
drag shows been normalized in our
culture
we're seeing them more and more on
television and commercials and your kids
can see them on television and
commercials and now what we're
this issue at hand here is
drag shows in front of children
and uh you take something that was you
know in the past was secretive and they
weren't
proud of it wasn't out in the open um
and now not only is it normalized in
society
but now it's being even forced
to where they want you to accept grown
men dancing in their underwear in front
of children
and then putting dollar bills in the
grown men's underwear
and that's where we've we've come and
it's it hasn't
it's not what it once was it was just
something that uh gay men did and behind
closed doors but now it's being pushed
down onto our children
and um
okay so
do you think
children should be attending drag shows
well not at all i mean we don't have we
don't let children in texas attend uh
strip clubs with a stripper i mean that
we have laws to protect children already
from adults who
intend bad things for them or to
sexualize them and so uh this is nothing
but sexualizing the child
um and it shouldn't be a foreign idea to
us right i mean you look at human
trafficking and the problem that is well
that's a large contingent of that is
adults wanting to have sex with children
and then now with the drag in front of
children they're not say taking just the
sexual qualities of a woman
putting those on display in front of
children and one of those children to
touch them and interact with them
and um and you know we want kids to
maintain their innocence we want kids to
um
know right and wrong and know when
they're you know safe and know when
they're in jeopardy and what we have
happening with the drag queens is we're
teaching them that it's okay to be
around a man dancing this way in his
underwear and it's okay for you to touch
him right but then
two months later another man has him
alone
is doing the same thing we want that kid
concerned we want that kid saying no no
this shouldn't be happening i need to
tell someone but we're we're literally
trying to teach these kids that it's
normal and okay to have adults
treat you this way and it it's
inappropriate for their behavior and
it's unethical to sexualize
children that is true um do you think
that there's any chance that
people who do these drag shows think
that they're just trying to
i guess
get children used to the idea of the
lgtpq
community so that they're less
prejudiced when they grow up
oh sure it's it's all of that it's
trying to
let the kids i guess be accepting and
they think as the kids get older they'll
be more accepting and and but it's it's
more than just that
um
you take
nambla north north american
association of man boy love or man boy
love association namlo they've been
around for 25 30 years or more actually
but as the lgbtq movement when it hadn't
always been known that but known as that
but whenever they've tried to advance
things whether it's same-sex marriage
whether it's whatever they've tried to
advance nabla has always been a part of
their movement and they've been wanting
to normalize adult men relationship with
adult voice that's their goal that's why
they exist and they're a part of these
movements
and during those times you had people in
the gay community going no no no we want
to advance this but we don't want
anything to do
with people that are taking advantage of
children they always really try to
distance themselves from nambu
but here we are now in our culture and
our society
and we don't see
uh
an active push to distance themselves
from namla and in fact they're you know
criticize me and others because we don't
want children
to be exposed to adults that are doing
all this sexual stuff
um
but yeah they want them to be accepted
and they also want them to participate
and then i would say even the end goal
is they're wanting these children to
then go and do gender modification
surgeries i don't think they're content
with accepting
i believe over the past 20 years 25
years if we've seen their movement
progress
by and large society's been accepted the
church has been accepting they've like
say they're normalized good good luck
finding a sitcom that doesn't have an
lgbtq character and all this right so
we've been accepting
but they keep pushing
and then uh you know that that's the
goal they're they're not just wanting to
accept they're wanting us
to engage in fact we had this happen on
the house floor when we were discussing
boys participating in girls college
sport or no high school sports
and we had members of the democrat party
that were upset with me and others
because we were using the words male and
female
during this conversation they wanted us
to use cis male and cis female
and so it wasn't agreed to disagree
it wasn't uh you know this is what we
believe we want you to accept and we'll
move on no they wanted us to change our
vocabulary to match theirs
and uh so there i mean you can say it's
acceptance but i believe that's just the
foot and the door
of of the movement and what they're
trying to do they're trying to normalize
every bit of it now not all of them are
you know not all every person in the
lgbtq community is trying to normalize
adult child relationships but there's a
contingent in there that is and right
now i'm not seeing people distance
themselves and also where do you draw
that line right i'm saying kids
shouldn't be around drag queens and you
know in a drag show and all that well if
they say it's okay well where do you
draw that line if a man can dance in
women's underwear kids put dollar bills
in their underwear
then when is it wrong
for an adult to do sexual things with
the child and they don't answer the
question
do you think there's any type of
consensus in that lgbtq community
about whether or not children should be
allowed to attend drag shows do you
think this is just one
small portion of it or do you think this
is kind of an overarching theme
well i don't know how big it is but i
know it's not all i mean whenever i put
out this idea the bill i do
we got calls from people in the
homosexual community had a guy call hey
i'm a homosexual from dallas i just want
you to know
i agree with you children should be
around drag queens
i mean
they're not unified on this because as
i've said there are people in the
homosexual community that's always tried
to distance themselves from the
pedophiles the namla
but right now not many are doing it we
got people you know calling and telling
us they support us but they know if they
come out publicly on social media
they're gonna get
absolutely blown up by their own side by
their own you know their own group
because they want all or nothing and so
but they're not unified
um what would you say to people who say
that the
the idea that the lgbtq community has um
a tendency towards pedophilia that's
just right-wing propaganda well
like i said not all right um but there
are some i mean the existence of nam
north american man boy love association
you can read on their website they've
had for a long time they want to
normalize relationships with children
they've been a part of every movement
the gay or lgbtq movement has had
they're there and it in through history
and recent history they people distance
themselves from them but they're still
there
and so um
like i say it is not all but here's
here's my point michaela so
let's pretend and just say
no one right no one in drag is a
pedophile let's just pretend that's the
reality
well
what they're teaching children and how
they're grooming children uh and and how
to the children is supposed to
respond to the way these adults are
dancing and interacting with them
it is not appropriate for the child if
the child
was in front of a
female stripper it's not appropriate as
i mentioned with human trafficking you
got men trying to have children and just
straight up pedophiles
that's all wrong i mean that is
absolutely all wrong and the idea of the
drag queen
dancing this way in front of a child and
you know the depiction and
characterization of a woman you would
think
would offend the left right it only take
basically two qualities of a woman and
they're saying hey kid look this is what
a woman is and you need to accept this
and celebrate this and it's not a great
characterization not a full character
depiction of what a woman is
and um
[Music]
and
the thing is they're leading these kids
to a doorstep right they're leading
these kids to things that are bad these
kids may not have the red flags up if
adults are trying bad things with them
so like say let's pretend that they
they don't have any pedophiles the
problem is is they're
grooming they're they're helping these
kids uh lower
uh
lower their guard
towards somebody who really does want to
harm them so i don't see how that's a
good thing
uh just
in that aspect what they're they're
leading kids down a path towards
okay so that's that's drag shows what
about uh
the drag queen story time that you've
heard i know that in toronto that was i
think they put it on at the zoo right so
what about those events i think it's
inappropriate for children the drag
queen exists
from a sexual
nature that's what it's the drag queen
is for they only take basically two
qualities of a woman and and they don't
they don't focus on intelligence they
don't focus on work ethic they don't
focus on anything nurturing they don't
focus on
just the sexual and the materialistic
side
and so why would we want to teach kids
that's what a woman is
why would we want to do that and besides
that
what what would be the benefit to having
a female stripper sit down and read to
the kids
that her her job she makes money
stripping
why does that
somehow make her
better at reading books or the kids
learn more she's in a sexually oriented
oriented business the drag queen is it's
sexually oriented it has no
place around children
so
see how it's appropriate
so you promise to file legislation to
protect children from drag shows can you
give us a bit of a description about
what that bill's about
yeah well to be honest with you we don't
know if it's going to be one bill or
four bills i mean we're just trying to
figure out where and how to do it in
texas
to stop this from happening as i've
mentioned we have it in texas law where
you know kids can't go to sexually
oriented oriented businesses they can't
go in liquor stores they can't go in
bars
they can't buy cigarettes etc there's a
lot of protections for kids so we want
to add
right now if kids were to have a
stripper dance in front of them it would
be a crime strippers in texas have to
have some type of license
and because they're sexually oriented in
their business
so i'm simply wanting to just
add the drag queen shows into what we
already have in law which is
classifying sexually or sexually
oriented businesses and keeping children
from being around them so i don't know
if that's going to be some type of you
know getting a license or just saying
hey kids you know can't participate
we don't know we're still working on it
but the goal is is
is to stop this apparently uh the way
the law is written
a man can dance in his underwear in
front of kids and have them stuff dollar
bills in their underwear but i mean
that's apparently legal in texas
and we need to stop that just as we've
done it with women that would try to
dance in front of
or i guess men wearing men's underwear i
guess the loophole might be that a man's
wearing women's underwear i guess i
don't know why but we had no sheriffs no
law enforcement trying to stop this at
any point in time
okay and is that because specifically
drag shows aren't classified as a strip
show they just were never written in
maybe
because this was never an issue before
that's right i mean yeah it was never an
issue
it was never thought of hey let's do
this in front of children and it will be
okay it will be accepted you know it was
never thought that until now we're like
i say the the
the drag queen is a part of our society
and culture and in our shows and
commercials i mean everywhere and so now
it's just
they're just pushing the envelope more
to more and more what they want they
don't want to just accept it in society
they want it in our interface i mean in
fact right after i said i was going to
file this piece of legislation there was
a an elected official in california said
they wanted to make drag queens
mandatory curriculum in the schools
they want more than just
you know observing a a drag queen shift
they wanted mandatory participation in
school
what do you think parents are thinking
when they
bring children to these events
that's a good question so the way i
described this because i was a youth and
family minister and and what i see
parents
um
you know they want their kid to get
through
high school be 18 years old going to
college and they don't want to have a
physical scar
an emotional scar
a psychological scar
i mean they don't right
parents want to protect their kids from
everything they don't want their kid to
even have a broken heart right they
they don't want a girlfriend or
boyfriend to break up with and and uh of
course we look at our society where they
all have to have trophies right everyone
wins they don't know what it's like to
lose and and so uh you know one thing
i've asked
to help explain this is imagine i show
up to your city any city
and i want to get a permit to do some
type of parade bike ride and the bike
ride is called the good old days
background only children can participate
and they're not allowed to wear helmet
elbow pads or knee pads do you think
that city
is going to give me a permit
definitely not no they are not
but you take any of the lgbtq
movement and you're gonna get pushback
that the gender modification of children
right
it's irreversible
they're okay with it
but they don't want the kid to ride on a
bike without
their knee pads elbow pads helmet and
then you got the drag queen which is a a
characterization of a woman highly
sexualized
and we don't want
our children to be exposed to pedophiles
we don't want our child to be exposed to
anything sexual we don't want our our
children um
doing anything other than enjoying their
childhood
but they want this sexualization to go
to be put on them and like like i've
mentioned
i don't understand why
why even the left wants to take
the depiction of a woman that a drag
queen displays
and show that to their kid and say this
is what a woman is i don't see how how
they want that so back to parents
you know
why would a parent
find it so important for their child to
be around this
and and and some of it comes down to
this
um
is some parents try to live through
their children
um i think a lot of things that happen
you have parents that have their own
insecurities
maybe they weren't as popular as they
wanted to be in high school maybe they
didn't have the boyfriend or girlfriend
they wanted
um
who knows what it could be and those
parents
take their children they try to live
through their their children and
in some cases you could have parents
that are trying to push this on their
child so that when they go to brunch
they can brag to their friends that
their child is
lgbtq or their child is accepting of
drag queens and they feel like
somehow that's
you know
a one-up on everybody there's people
talking about maybe a new car a new
house or a new job and they're like oh
yeah well you know they use it as a
bragging right because it's about their
insecurities
um so that would be one possibility
um
the other thing i think there's some
parents who who just don't understand
how dangerous it is to sexualize a child
whether it's towards the lgbtq
or sexualize them towards a
you know heterosexual pedophile right i
mean it it's both wrong and bad
on that child and and so why they do it
i don't fully know the answer
i haven't also heard parents say you
know how dare you say i can't take my
child to a drag queen and also if i want
to take my kid in a strip club y'all
better repeal that law so we can do that
too
so they're only doing it for one thing
and it's in the drag queen they're not
trying to do it anywhere else they don't
want the freedom and liberty to do it in
any other situation
so i think it has more to do with their
ideology
they support the lgbtq movement they
want to advance it everywhere they can
um
and
and so that that's that's what's driving
this and and
yeah it's a
yeah that's all i can say is there
there's probably a lot of reasons but it
has mostly to do with their own
insecurities and they're just
it's ideology you know
their ideology is sensitive to the lgbtq
movement
okay um
so in your opinion should drag shows
be banned altogether or should they just
be limited to 18 or 21 what do you think
would be reasonable for the future
so my bill simply said keep drag shows
away from children what i'm
trying to work on i'm not trying to end
drag shows altogether
um
i mean
do they need to exist well that's
another
you know as far as the direct shows and
everything in in our society hey
somebody somebody can have that
conversation
i just see
uh the need to protect children is all
i'm doing now what age do we put that at
18 or 21
i mean that's up to debate really
because when a child turns 18
uh they could go you know
um well actually
just now in texas we changed the law to
where it's 20 you have to be 21 years
old to work in strip club so
i guess now
as of
last september i guess it would probably
be more appropriate to move it to 21 to
treat them all treat all that
sexually oriented business the same
um but you know at 18 the kids could go
you know do all the cosmetic surgery for
the gender modification they could you
know dance they they could put on a
dress they could go wherever they want
you know they're adults but in texas we
we do now have a law saying 21 so i mean
right now i guess everything would lean
towards 21 but open to discussion
um
what
what can a parent do if they don't want
their kid to see drag or be exposed to
kind of this ideology you're going to
see it everywhere you see it in
commercials
depends on where you are apparently like
say from what we've learned if you
attend school in california you may want
to consider pulling your kid out of
school there in california because
there's a guy there that wants to make
it mandatory curriculum um
uh you're just going to have to
one just
don't drive them there if there's a show
but uh but the problem is is uh
i say it's been a part of the plan part
of the process to normalize this as we
see it more and more in tv we have to
worry about the books your kids are
reading um i live east of dallas in in
east texas we have all those books all
the porn books are in all the school
districts
in my district it's not an urban problem
it's not a california problem it's
everywhere so parents are just gonna
have to be on guard if you want to
protect your kid help them maintain
their innocence and just
enjoy their childhood grow up be ready
to be a good productive adult you're
going to have to protect them
bottom line protect them and you're
going to have to look at everything
minimize online
minimize or cut out social media
things like that
what kind of books are you talking about
so uh we found books and libraries in
rural
all over texas but in my district that
um some of the books depict adult child
sex
adult child you know oral sex
even you know lgbtq i mean all
sexualization of children even you know
child child sex i mean it's just totally
inappropriate um you know it's it's
books that if if
you or i
took somewhere else and showed a kid
we'd probably go to jail
but the schools have them in their
library and kids could be reading these
checking these out and once again it's
it's all in the same nerve i mean you
got the
the books that are basically porn you
got drag queens wanting to perform in
front of the children and then you got
the gender modification of children it's
all the same thing
they're all trying to sexualize the
child
and do so before they're an adult and
and
i'll just say this real quick i know you
asked about the books
um
what i've asked people if we've been
discussing this issue with children
um
with the gender modification i guess
with that one is you know the question i
always like to ask or back when i was in
the ministry uh i'd ask people is what
if you're wrong
what if i'm wrong
and so you know 10 years from now if we
all look back and and decide that you
know let's say
you know my side was wrong that kids
shouldn't be sexualized shouldn't go
through gender modification if we're
wrong
the worst case scenario is that child
has to wait till they're 18
to go through and do all that surgeries
go through you know go be a drag queen
whatever they'd have to wait till
they're 18.
the other side
what if they're wrong
if they're wrong
there's no going back
if that child wind up getting gender
modification surgery you don't reverse
that that child's life is forever
on a
a different path
never go back
and the sexualization of children i mean
there's a lot of things uh
that once you get the child so focused
on sex and in their guard down anything
could happen they could get caught up in
human trafficking as a sex slave they
could become you know pregnant as a
child uh there's just so many things can
happen
and uh if if they're wrong and if if i'm
wrong
well you just gotta wait till you're 18
which is what we want for kids with a
lot of things
so but these books
um they just are part of the same nerve
uh of sexualizing our children
why do you think this has made it
into the schools specifically like why
is it that part of society that seems to
be pushing this
that is a good question
um
well you know
as we
as children develop and grow
um
and you you shape them into how they
think that's how they'll be
you know as they get older i've always
told parents that and i've told
teenagers this
that by the age of 12 13 14
if you haven't figured out how to be an
honest person
um they're gonna you know tell the truth
that you're you're gonna
be moral if you you know those type of
things that's who you're gonna be if if
by the time you're 14 more than likely
and so it's very important that as kids
as
very young kids that they you train them
and you teach them how to live how to
think how to be moral how to be ethical
because then they will continue to do
that so then there's people who uh as we
mentioned earlier with acceptance they
think hey if we can get these children
to believe it's okay for an adult to act
this way with them well then as they get
older they'll accept all of them and
it'll be a world to be a happy place
but um
but
that's what they would be doing they'd
be teaching children uh this sexual um
aspect and sexual nature and as that kid
gets or older that's gonna be their
focus and so um so it's kind of a it's a
fight for our a battle for our youth
battle for
the children because they're going to
determine what our society is
and so um
and so
they think i guess they think that's
that's where they want to win the battle
because if we raise children to be moral
and ethical we raise children to know
right and wrong we raise children to
know that adults should not do sexual
things with children
they can't win that conversation with
the 25 year old
but if that at eight years old the
child's taught it's okay then that child
is 25 i mean so that
yeah i i guess
and they're doing in school because that
they're trying to
win the battle 10 years from now
how do you think it's appropriate to
teach kids
you know so so i i would assume from
that angle they're saying
what they're saying anyway is we need to
expose kids to these ideas so they grow
up like you said and aren't bigoted or
aren't prejudiced um do you think
there's an appropriate way to teach kids
so that they don't end up prejudiced
that doesn't involve this kind of
hypersexualization
sure it's from a christian worldview
i mean uh the bible teaches us
right and wrong the bible teaches us
god's plan and that he made male and
female
bible teaches us that also teaches us to
be loving to others
um and so uh
uh
yeah i mean we've been doing it and and
yes there's been some bad actors right
there's been people do bad things but
guess what
we live in a fallen world people do evil
things but that doesn't mean
that
god is flawed doesn't mean that you know
christianity's flawed because one person
you know or however many make a bad
decision
so
so we
we
teach kids how to treat others we teach
kids what god expects of us and who we
are because that's a lot of this is
in the lgbtq movement they're teaching
these children that
you know
they're not teaching them god made you
and made you perfect the way you are
they're saying
if you think that you're something other
that somehow it was a mistake let's fix
that
and and they're they're trying to go
against um how god has made you i mean i
saw this as a youth and family minister
i saw girls uh in the youth group with
blonde hair which they had dark and
girls with dark hair which they have
blonde hair and then you have curly hair
and then straight hair and uh we haven't
taught kids how to live with
insecurities and how to be content with
who you are
um and
and so we have to come at it with a
biblical worldview in my opinion
and um
that's that's the way we do it um it's
worked before and i'll also say this
i worked at some rural country churches
and there's always some old men there
they would say you know uh these kids
out here in the country you never had to
teach them a sex ed class in school
they figured it out from the animals you
know i mean they they saw what happened
they knew what happened and they were
they got it neo parents talk to them but
um
but
basically
you know maybe maybe the church isn't
doing a good job of of teaching you know
i believe a lot of the problems we have
in our culture
all start with
the lack of leadership we have in the
pulpit in america
i think a lot of people also that um
aren't brought up
uh
with a christian background
kind of scoff at it and just look at it
as another type of ideology
i think that's part of the problem um
you mentioned
you mentioned that the bible teaches
people to love one another
and
that seems like it might be a good place
to start
right for acceptance is don't be hateful
that's that's pretty much that's like
that seems like a pretty good lesson
just to begin with that everybody could
learn from yeah i'll tell you this
growing up
um
my family we worked in miss texas page
uh most people wouldn't think that about
me i'm in the hall of fame miss texas
organization and that's mainly because i
was big enough to carry bots
but we were around a
homosexual community working in that and
um and like say
i feel like i'm loving accepting i mean
like i say have lots of people
i know that are gay
my thing is just keep it away from kids
you know leave kids alone i don't care
if you're heterosexual or homosexual or
drag
leave kids alone
it's that simple
and um
but
for some reason it's it's
treated as taboo if you want to protect
kids from drag
when like i say the whole nature concept
of drag is
sexualization
and so
anyway
it's wild that we're where we're at you
know and and that just because you say
you don't want kids to be around drag
shows they think you know
you you hate others no
i don't
um i just also believe god has a you
know standard how he wants us to live
our life
everybody's got to answer for their
decisions
okay well that covers all the questions
i had um
if people want to learn more about you
is there any place they can go online
sure yeah you can find me on facebook
you can find me on twitter uh
brianforhd2
and then you can find me on my website
at brianslayton.com
okay great thank you very much for
taking part in the supposing views thank
you michaela for having me